well it's been a big week for viral
videos celeb meltdowns first there was
Chloe grace Moretz reaming out newcomer
Brian Butler from the downloader and
then our good buddy Kevin Donnelly got
the business from none other than
Kristen Bell on the red carpet of the
boss whoo that was nasty a lot of people
say this could be the end for the
legendary correspondent we invited Kevin
over this morning to set the record
straight
is he here with that yeah I was there oh
did you piece it on the chairs I'm so
tired okay because you please sit on the
chair Jesus pretty I've never seen you
run before what happened Kevin got fired
that is so super sad brim you okay I
don't think so this morning at 6:00 a.m.
he tweeted
we got it lots of oohs this is not good
for the guy I mean they're probably
gonna replace him today I go like right
now to a me you're both the worst humans
ever you know that right you two I have
dreams
things were not good
I'm the one who stomping into this whole
town for 28 years and now I'm in
my car
Patito get my head straight I'm
sorry I'm being so rude right now okay
so like um roses movie fun to make yeah
yeah it was really fun interesting
that's why I love this character you
know George honey he's more than just a
judge you know yes yes just hello get
some good news yeah you don't huh okay
so what are you wearing under the robe
I'm asking you a question
you should probably you should probably
put that down I can't yeah I can come in
right now yeah yeah I'll be I'll be
there huh
on my way I just I got ya we under
attack or something what I should be
another father than that mom
I know what you're on your phone about I
figured it out
it's the Kevin Donnelly job thing oh no
I'm just watching this video it's got a
panda with the little paper jetpack on
it can you keep a secret I just got off
the phone with my reps apparently it's
down to me and one other person for
Kevin's job at the fix so I could get
the job and then I launched my line of
cream juices and then my red juices and
then my beige juices I never had the
chance to tell you but I really admire
you and your work out thank you so much
that is so nice you know I never
actually had an opinion about you but
after you said that nice thing about me
I like you thank you yeah I'm not going
back any of these people are
crazy just have the carpet nip on the
side entrance okay I'm kinda back
hey there Kevin hey wow you look like
someone in your cornflakes this one
of the man you okay just just can you
leave me alone okay okay if you're here
to give me like a pep talk or try to
cheer me up or anything like that it's
nothing about talk I just I want to tell
you a story I was born in st. Louis
Missouri and ever since I can remember
all I wanted to do was be a part of the
storytelling process changed my life and
so I went to New York and I said no dad
these are my dreams I had to answer
phones at an advertising agency called
Messner battery Berger McNamee
schmaderer can you say that neither
could i I found out that I had a voice
so now Yankee Doodle went to town riding
on a pony camptown races see come on
dude Oh
yeah that's when I realized that judge
honey's perfect for the whole family
I don't know how that's really relevant
well there's no it's not relevant to you
I never got a chance to talk about
myself today with all you self-involved
pricks and your cell phones and running
out cuz I'm the one that's gonna have
the crisis right here oh my god I'm so
sorry one in my car man I'm with Ross
I'm in junket mode today I'm like just
god I'm all about my narrative you this
is easy man you need to stop being a
garbage human being you have a girl you
have a guy I've had a girl she's in
there and she's trying to leave me so go
get her tiger but you should shower
first you smell like do it
toys woman literally it's bad it's
permeating the whole car I smelled it
before I even got here Brittany oh my
god Kevin listen Matt Bomer just told me
the meaning of life please take me back
please forgive me for everything I
promise I won't disappoint you let me
think about it
no you hello this is Brian yes what
of course thank you so much brother
I just got the job at the fix what what
that's gonna be some kind of a thing
it is like a mistake I think the goddamn
patriarchy I'm so happy for you
hey enjoy your 8 minutes
hey keV
it lets you thank you oh wow hey hi hey
listen um guess what didn't just go well
what what's that me coming back in here
and trying to get you know being the
tiger and everything
thanks for the shitty advice
whoa whoa buddy
no no of my career I thought it was
before no it's super I was
gonna cut you fall apart I just got
super and you know what it was
because you're what not take it easy
with don't sing easy with this
thing away from me stand up I'm gonna go
outside I'm gonna be by my car and
you're gonna come out there and I'm
gonna show you what it's like to be
super fogged are you rolling